plage de mont d'ohrid
c'est pas avec très dur
bonjour j'ai perdu ma tête ou les as tu
vu pour la dernière fois
et oui tu sais tu as des petites
problèmes de mémoire
oui un petit peu plus de courage dans le
2 un petit peu plus d'expérience dans le
2 mai il est toujours aussi un peu trop
prudent toujours mais toi la girouette
6e b bonjour je m'appelle d'ériger c'est
donc le pool fugueurs donc il sans arrêt
en train de se barrer pour essayer de
trouver une sortie
c'est vraiment un super personnage parce
qu'au début des râleurs il tape veulent
un peu lâche
et petit à petit on découvre que c'est
un vrai héros harry oui oui destinée
c'est un requin baleine
si la tache bleue qui parle vous pouvez
peut-être m'aider je cherche mes parents
où chercher vos parents alors est
comment myope ce qui est très bien parce
que moi aussi c'est très très dur à
faire leçon baleine moi quand je le fais
par moments ça fait bizarrement ça fait
suisse ça vous ennuie raid pas les moins
forts j'ai mal à la tête mon personnage
s'appelle baylet je leur ai dit que je
sais que tu parle de moi dessinée roi
qu'il peut plus servir de son sonar mais
j'ai encore des limites cynisme je suis
là seulement j'entends absolument tout
ce que tu dis sur moi on a essayé d'en
faire un vrai personnage pour la france
marrant quoi vraiment drôle chaque fois
qu'il ouvre la bouche on rit à chaque
fois qu'ils qui se réalise on se réalise
avec lui et ça c'est cool c'est très
drôle c'est extrêmement bien fait faire
tout est poussé réalisme tellement fort
que forcément bas on y croit et que
forcément rentrer dans l'histoire
ces haltes ans est monté à une vitesse
cc on veut savoir ce qui se passe après
rendez vous le 22 juin dans l'essonne a
très vite